many new writers say that it's nearly
impossible to get their scripts to
people that actually have the power to
buy them or greenlight them but that's
their problem there did the access yeah
what are your thoughts on that and
that's the reason they're not me sorry
yeah I would I would say they don't know
how lucky they are as of today it
depends you have to get used to the
system you have I've for instance back
in back in the day back in my day there
was one way into Hollywood TV film one
way and that was through an agent's
front door and that agents front door
had layers and layers of guardians
before it and that was also frustrating
you know in a similar way but very very
frustrating to Gideon but now what you
have you have a more creative path let
me put it this way contests
screenwriting contests have now been
around long enough to separate the wheat
from the chaff
you know the good ones a year after year
have gotten stronger because you know
more people believe in them and the less
good ones although they're all sincere I
know they're all sincere have kind of
fallen and fallen by the wayside but the
test is this every time I hear that I
mean yes I have great sympathy for that
I understand that I remember when I was
coming up myself and what it felt like
and it was infuriating and frustrating
the number one reason why you are not
making it is the material is not yet
good enough because you if you're not
especially if you're not reading you
know that reading the stuff that's out
there you have no way of knowing how
good good has to be in order to get
noticed and coming in you have to be
better than most of the people who are
now making a living at it in order to
get noticed even but the contests offer
you know the most I'm a tree
objectification the contests offer a
concrete way to do
work on it and work on it and work on it
until you've got something you're ready
to test but now pick your contests
carefully the first time you try it out
pick smaller contests more more fringing
I mean do your research they should be
decent upstanding contests and so forth
try it out try it out did you make the
quarterfinals or were you swept away you
know in in the first pass through okay
if that happens you have learned
something it's not ready and you keep
working on it and you keep working on it
and finally when you know you get to the
mid-level ranks and let's say it gets
your your script gets to the
quarterfinals okay but it did not make
the top 10 or top 15 fine you've learned
something more go back take a vacation
for a couple of weeks try not to think
about it then read it again make more
notes and go back to work on it and it
is a way to that's the thing see what
what what a lot of neophyte
screenwriters new screenwriters don't do
or don't pursue which is you have got to
be as a writer as a craftsperson you
must be relentless in your goal of
creating quality material for instance
I'll give you for instance and maybe
that was sort of I'm working with a
young lady right now who was one of our
grad students a few years a couple two
three years ago she's been my assistant
class assistant and stuff like that so
we know each other pretty well
she took her thesis screenplay from I
don't know three years ago and I read it
and I told her you got a great idea here
you know you really do I believe in this
idea and we had conversations about you
know there's no such thing as a bad
screenplay only an unfinished one and
all that
and I gave her some pointers and you
know scribbled things on the pages and
she went back and she wrote it again
this is a feature film and I looked at
it you know this is better this is a
little better and I went through at the
end you know the sample editing and
scribble scribble and all this kind of
stuff and then she takes it and she
comes back and it's a little bit better
she has been through that process
well in this case with me oh it must be
six times now I mean years have passed I
mean that was she this she she had a
draft of this when she went up for her
thesis three years ago right but I'll
tell ya and I'm I'm reading it once
again I'll probably be looking at it
again this weekend she is so close so
close what I would really like to I kept
telling her keep track of don't lose
your draft of your of your first draft
don't lose a copy of your first draft
because a day is coming I would like to
have that in my hand and your final
draft and put that together in a binder
and use this in class have people read
the first draft and now read the last
draft and that I believe could be a
wonderful wonderful exploration of
teaching and screenwriting because this
has become viable
she is now close to having a an entirely
shootable casting really good social
commentary screenplay what changed in
those six drafts over the three years or
how for many craft craft her mastery of
I mean what most of them do is they
write what they mean when they come to
dialogue people just blurt it out and
it's called on-the-nose dialogue that's
one of the things you teach stop it
people do not talk like that people talk
around what they mean not that there
can't be confrontation and stuff like
that under certain emotional
circumstances yes but it was dialogue
and less is more in terms of the amount
of dialogue in description it was about
the use of language and vocabulary in
description using irrelevant words the
and there there's a whole list of
there's the nine most utterly useless
words I got it back there on a sheet I
pass out sometimes all that is is filler
all that does is slow the reader down it
is developing a style in the way you
describe and and offer exposition and
description in in scene with seen
heading slug lines and then what we're
looking at and stuff like that drawing
people in where you put things the plot
building the plot in an ever better way
you can do more here you could do more
here that's what's been going on for all
those years so you liked her initial
idea of the story
absolutely and it's so and it was in
very rough form very rough form she had
written badly with pride and in Neath
underneath that there had been there's
just something that really struck me you
know this is this is worth saying and
this is important to say it's a social
commentary piece it's not like there's a
big market out there for social
commentary pieces there isn't but say
okay but it has to be done incredibly
well to catch the eyes you want to catch
we said never gonna be made I don't know
if it's ever going to be made or not
that's out of our hands
but I am so proud of her boy she has got
a work sample for the ages so and you've
let her know not not too soon because
once she takes this brilliant idea and
it's not ready that's the end of shooter
in the that is correct time and again oh
she was planning two years ago to send
it off to one of the majors I don't know
I don't know what's it's a script up a
loser or what one of the majors you know
and she asked to take one more look at
it before sent it off I said I think
you're it's self-defeating to send this
off yet and she there was a small
contest it's the BFA broadcast Education
Association has a student thing every
year and they have contests a short-film
contest of four students and scripts and
so forth I said try it there try it
there and she did and she learned some
stuff she learned some stuff and she
also learned that that sometimes judges
can be jerks and that's part of the mix
too but she learned she kept working and
it got better that is how you write
everybody who says you know you got a
spring once when I was coming up I said
you got to crank out a brand new
screenplay every six months that's a
that is insane I'm sorry you can't do
good work if you're doing that no you
have to live with it you have to grow
with it you have to be able to go back
and read it again and again and yet
again drives my wife nuts when I was
working on the book you know I was
already it was ready to senator the
period the publisher and she said you're
sitting down to read it again what is
wrong with you I said honey you you
married a mad man I mean that that goes
with the territory that's what writers
do and I read it again and I found
mistakes and I fixed them it's endless
so the the best thing for a writer is to
have been born a bit obsessive
compulsive it's like that is a trait
that the craft requires of us
you don't just - it off you don't and do
it well
you